hey guys hot sessions number four at
this point I'm not gonna do the whole
intro like I've done the other three
hopefully hopefully if you've been
listening along you've got the context
of the show bringing people together
that I'm interested in from afar some I
know really well some I'm just getting
to know some just a meeting for the
first time and I've really enjoyed it
this format has been super interesting I
think we're getting better and better at
mixing up the crew and I'll be really
honest apologize to the other three
sessions that started us off I think
this is gonna be the best one yet and so
introduce we will start with ladies
first why don't you treat yourself and
give a quick little line about your jam
what you do and then and then we'll take
it from there I am Hannah Bronfman
thanks so much for having me
course um I run a wellness media company
called HP fit I'm also a DJ and I curate
and create content for myself my company
and a lot of other companies as well
awesome
I'm Nik Stauskas a professional
basketball player for the Brooklyn Nets
got traded here a couple of months ago
it's my fourth year in the league and
I'm a huge fan of the show huge fan of
Gary and it just had the best one-on-one
meeting I mean we did have a pretty good
one and a lot of it what's up guys ill
mind I'm a music producer four-time
grammy nominated for time yeah that's us
grammy loser ready for that worked with
you know Jay Cole Kanye West Kendrick
just dropped at a black panther album
and produced X with my man thank you
with my man Soundwave shout to my wife
asked me about you being in it today
nice icon well I did I did do a Milan oh
you're welcome
Disney with Lee manuel's yeah I did some
stuff with Lynn and just kind of you
know here happy to be here man Larry V's
man so uh this is a really fun format
and the thing that I'm starting all
these shows with has been really fun to
explore I want to go back around the
circle and ask you what you are
currently obsessed with now a couple
episodes ago the crew went like really
like world peace and like you know like
like very vague calmly [ __ ] I mean
like not [ __ ] maybe they are
actually passionate about world peace
but I
something subtle right like like this
new marker you have or your new
teammates haircut or a new up-and-coming
kids song or something outside your
genre like you know just like you're
obsessed with like fixing the pothole on
your street
what are you currently obsessed with
Hannah okay well I mean besides multiple
beauty products cuz that's like a daily
obsession and something new yes but
really though yeah really really really
really I'm obsessed with this company
that I'm advising and it's like a crazy
data company that basically scrapes all
of your Instagram comments and can tell
the intent of a user to buy something
got it so that's what I'm obsessed with
right now I kind of want to know like
they could basically tell me if I wanted
to put out a product what product that
would be based on so you're right about
the data I am right now I'm obsessed are
you nerding out on it I am yeah I'm just
thinking about all the [ __ ] I yeah it's
kind of incredible because then you can
also start to tailor your own content of
course and right so you use it to like
exactly so are we gonna see like avocado
face masks for me it all sorts of really
you say that because I've been thinking
about a new series called face masks in
the wild where you're literally putting
on like a face mask and going out to do
like normal things so didn't see me in
an avocado I should have worn one today
to be honest no this is something I'm
currently obsessed with so like I mean
yes being a professional athlete like
what I eat and like what I put in my
body is yes warden
yes and there's this I don't know maybe
you guys have been there it's called
sweet green yeah I love 1999 there is a
sweet green in Philly but I had no idea
that I guess like I thought sweet green
was just in Philly to be honest with you
so I so like over the last couple of
months I have like I'm talking about
like do you did every meal every day I
have sweet green like it's my favorite
dressing balsamic like I have to have
the balsamic dressing
his head see me for me it's the cashew
peanut but that's I've never even tried
that one I've heard it's a good with me
I'm one of those guys that's like once I
find something that works for me or that
I like good all then I don't try
anything else what were you eating
before this before you switched you
don't even remember what was life I was
I can't even see them and like I didn't
have a go to I didn't have a go to place
although I did like a Philly cheesesteak
everyday too many of those yeah yeah man
but aside from Star Wars and Game of
Thrones
I want to go really really really now
I'm actually I've just been getting into
and being obsessed with different ways
to compose music so like you know you
have this like this you know the black
and white key piano yes has been the
main instrument for me you know your DJ
so like the pianos being our main
instrument for hundreds of years or
thousands of years so now with
technology there's ways to trigger chord
progressions and different melodies on
your phone like being able to not not
play an instrument but be able to
compose full melodies with triggering on
the phone and so in doing my research
I'm like downloading all these apps on
my phone and there's actually these like
new pieces of hardware that allow for
you to compose like full professional
pieces of music and access like you know
gospel chord progressions that you would
need you know years of training to
access but now I can do it with the push
of a button so I just think that's the
music you can't no you literally can so
I'm kind of obsessed with being a music
producer and being like trained in music
but then also using that technology
today being a fancy romantic exact and
instead of saying that's [ __ ] and
being sad that you had all these years
being open to it and riding yeah yeah
also to like it's weird
also to like where music is headed
because of that I mean
get a random kid download fruityloops
and be able to you know compose an
amazing piece of music I mean how is
that gonna shake up the it's gonna
change the supply and demand of
operative it's just the same old game
right the Internet is the middleman
technology squeezes the middle and we're
like in it now I think the next the next
thing is Holograms you know putting the
glasses on and then composing in the air
wow that's crazy exactly like imagine
Pro Tools but like moving the way
usually it's like very Minority Report
yeah Minority Report yeah yeah I
actually think we were that technology
on Holograms and VR that we will never
get to the place where we're really
wearing glasses at scale that by the
time the technology gets good enough
that we're all deep into that world well
be into contact lenses yeah and I do you
think that's in our lifetime I don't you
protecting so I think the next big one
is in-ear and then the one after that
will be in I I think in ear is gonna be
a lot of fun because it eliminates
language like I love the fact that I'll
be able to go to mainland China or India
and like we're just talking to each
other cuz it's translating for me in my
native language yeah but here's my
question I real quick so if you're in
seventh grade Spanish [ __ ] mail it in
it's not gonna [ __ ] it right because
that this technology is coming in it
will break down so many barriers do you
think that learning other languages will
become obsolete and it will be
commoditized so it's not that it's
obsolete and you're more than welcome
but yes it is not as valuable as it was
in the same way that it's not as
valuable today to memorize who the
presidents of the United States were
because we have a phone on us and we can
look it up but you still have to do that
in school
yeah but schools broken for the reality
the marketplace will school be fixed by
the time that probably not right my son
creates the problem well the problem
exists now right broken school is
causing real problems because people are
sitting with enormous college debt
mm-hmm and they don't have they don't
have leverage to close the gap on that
debt post school and they aren't being
taught skills that matter as much in
today's environment when you were going
into a job in the corporate world I mean
listen college was a great machine for a
1950s 60s 70s 80s 90s
and it hit its apex but it's now clearly
on the decline and no I don't know I
mean I'm unbelievably down on the
education system that is in place right
now to an extreme mm-hmm so um let's
talk about music for a minute emerging
artists obviously you know I have a lot
of passion but have boyd's in the room
that's been are jammed for 10 years so
yeah whoo you know you've got you know I
know you [ __ ] with a lot of people so
it's hardly I'm putting you on a tougher
spot where like I know there's 31 kids
that you think really have real
potential hmm but for fun and it just is
what it is it's not like you're not
naming somebody else if I put you in a
corner which I am who's an emerging
artist that most people won't know that
you're like wow if I had a bet and I'll
be really happy in four years when iris
sends me the clip of this uh-huh and I
was super right about this person Oh
who's that kid right now oh man there's
there's a there's a I'm trying to narrow
it down in my mind um while you're doing
that give I'm gonna let you really think
about this I'm gonna ask Nick I got it I
got it you guys got it yet um this girl
glam glam GL a.m. it stands for good
lyrics and music and so she's from yeah
glam she's from Oakland she lives in New
York she raps she sings she produces all
of her own music
I didn't dabble you don't but she does
all her [ __ ] and she's kind of if I can
if I can kind of describe her sound
she's Missy meets I notice his bite ya
know this is what it's like Missy fun
but Oakland very likely is sounding too
short yeah you can say that yeah but
it's like soulful and fun and like
upbeat uh but like she got bars too she
could rap she's [ __ ] amazing
SoundCloud Spotify
yeah she's both she's both but she
doesn't have that much like new stuff
out well that's good but she's cooking
man she's amazing who's gonna win the
NCAA tournament this year obviously you
had a really fun career in Michigan like
who's gonna win this year's n-c-double-a
March Madness
it's coming it's gonna be here any
minute
I mean once it comes to tournament your
guess is as good as mine
I mean anything really happens interment
last year that's actually crazy like my
you know my alma mater Michigan they
were like bottom of the big ten
throughout the entire scene and they was
not they went to the big ten tournament
and they are taking off the runway on
the plane to go to the big ten
tournament and their plane crashed
that's right and there when their plane
crashed like everyone got off the plane
like really traumatic experience and
coach like looked at them was like do
you guys still want to go like we can
call off the season right now like we
can forfeit and seasons done and the
players like we're going they win the
big Bantam going as like a bottom seed
they win the big 10 tournament get a
seed in the NCAA tournament and then
make it to the sweet 16 so like there's
really no telling if I had to guess I'd
say really don't want to say Michigan
State right I'm just gonna say has no
chance listening Michigan State has a
huge huge right I guess I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go at Duke like this kid Marvin
Bagley yeah at Duke he's he's gonna be a
prize so if I had to guess I'm gonna go
at Duke if not I'm just gonna go with
Michigan and hope they make a run this
year Hanna what is your favorite
restaurant end or actual like meal right
now like could be fast casual
what-have-you but like what food are you
like really thinking about and I'd love
to know restaurant if there has been one
in the last six months or so interesting
well there's a few I mean okay for
Charles has like the best burger in the
city right now and it's like the
atmosphere the burger everything about
it is package is amazing for Charles I'd
like for the number four yeah and write
it down and then I can you sub can you
set it up one of my meetings there right
now can you actually while we're doing
this podcast edit a meeting I'm having
the person send the invite reset it it's
hard to get a reservation so Monday
night might be ambitious but maybe for
you Mary they'll make it happen I don't
know let's change it let's buy for
Charles
I'm kidding and then I played humble
I'll go with my side up in the [ __ ]
there's another place called nerd that's
the hardest place to get into the city
right now for Charles has a really crazy
yeah who else
it's so cool to hang out with cool
people like I said I get the information
nur is really hard to get into right now
so leave your answers happen to be also
super host and I mean we're not provide
enough people I think I cook at home
mostly because I love to cook yeah it's
like a very therapeutic thing for me I
also care a lot about what I put in my
body and what not sure no I just said
that the best burger but it is one of
those burgers that you kind of just
would try um it's probably like six
months old whose plate crowd egos every
other week its rowdy here where I know a
guy actually has a standing reservation
every Tuesday night and he's always
trying to get rid of them cuz he can't
go every week so maybe I can throw you
on or something so there's this other
place called nur which is like a new
Israeli place that opened up that's
supposed to be where as raizy it's in
Flatiron and I haven't been there yet
but it's you're gonna go I'm dying to go
ya know yeah Wow
what uh what do you want to know what's
on your mind what do you what can I
answer what can one of the two three of
us answer like yo man what's on your
mind man I want to know I want to know
if it really is worth it
- yep I mean you talk about this [ __ ]
all the time like putting putting it put
yourself all in on something
yes like is it really worth it to go all
in in my world
on the social media this is so like go
all-in on you to go all-in on on all the
platforms yes let me commit yes let me
tell you why it is grossly underpriced
attention yeah and it gives you the
leverage yeah I mean I agree I just yeah
I just love me I mean a movie I just
came from a meeting with YouTube and
like took a deep dive into Elizabeth Ben
Mason yeah well yeah yeah
that's a meeting what do you tell you
though I mean you told me so many things
but well specifically my youtube channel
is Department amazing you have an HP fan
so I guess we basically went straight
into what's working what's not working
where we can tailor how we can optimize
and like I'm just calling me sorry bro
no it's all good no he's out it can at
first I was like damn there's a lot of
[ __ ] I need to be implementing and doing
differently yeah but like I'm really
glad that I like put out the content
that I put out so I have stuff to at
least go off of and know what to change
and where did you can not do all that
stuff kind of seemed a little
overwhelming at first but I also have
like some girl who is awesome and at
school wanted to use HP fit as a case
study so I have her implementing all the
fine dishes more importantly to that
point Hannah like like guys this is
financially viable to do I think like
meaning like if you're in a place where
you can afford it like like do it like
like 17 people and I'm about to go I
mean I just upped my Instagram ad spend
by a multiple of 12 like this is real
this is a moment this is why real
crushing it like I didn't write it just
write it I wrote it because I'm like
[ __ ] the thing I believed nine years ago
which I ended up being very right about
hmm I'm actually still under estimating
it this is so [ __ ] huge
hmm yeah yeah I think for me I just want
to make sure I am going all in well
using you you put the [ __ ] battery in
my back I saw that we had that meeting
the car and I like literally watched you
go do the right thing by YouTube
Instagram making the memes like I'm
watching him like he's [ __ ] doing it
what has happened
let's stream growth well what the flick
and what about outside of the ciphers
and things that like what about in real
life like I mean extreme growth
colleagues people that I was cool with
now you know stepping in and wanting to
do more because they're seeing more of
it and then they're just seeing the the
the audience grow opportunity
opportunity or like awareness you're
like I mean honestly I I've
looking at your page - and I think that
what you do is like not a lot of people
in the producing and the music making
world put out content the way that
you've not one I'm trying to get these
muhfuckas alike you know let's do this
together because my community is super
undereducated right and you can be as
inclusive as I wanna trust as you want
to be right this is literally story of
my life like it started with wine in
2006 like yeah you're the guy in 2006
and I believe in this [ __ ] like it was
YouTube nobody had ever heard of it like
it was five months old there wasn't a
video that had million views yet ever
like and it was raised it's really a
different world when I started and like
nobody knew nobody knew anything about
wine that was under 35 like and and it
was just like I wanted to educate I
wanted people to try new [ __ ] I was
tired of people drinking the same 15
kinds of wines when there was like four
thousand kinds of wines worth drinking
and then it happened with just
entrepreneurship in general like there's
a lot more people that do the kind of
thing that I do on Instagram every day
but to your point like when a producer
music producer does it I think the
athlete journey Nick to be honest really
like just like like bro you've said to
me in the meeting earlier like okay so
in the gym for two hours and I was just
like laughing I was like people think
they want to be basketball players
you're in the gym for two hours every
day and that's just that's just with the
ball then you go work out like I don't
think people understand and so what I
told you earlier like like I just had
these kids in here when I drew all over
my table like from twenty to thirty I
did nothing I went all in no outs no out
no out no out no burger place no Club no
all my friends up 42 all my friends now
who are the same age to like remember I
was like no no I never went to swear no
I don't know it like I don't know tunnel
like I don't know and I [ __ ] worked
yeah like like and and so like to me
that's not by the way the right answer
it's just you need to know what the cost
of your ambition is mm-hmm
like so like I could have been less
successful professionally and had some
balance and fun that's fine I could have
it's just not what I want like and you
have to understand what you want and
what you're trying to achieve but yes
all in every [ __ ] person listening to
this and if you're listening to me
ready in the consideration set of
debating if you're even listening to
this right now the answer is yes because
if I twenty two months ago needed to
remind my own self I need to go all-in
everybody needs reminding yeah true what
do you want to known it I mean obviously
you and I had our 101 so what about more
generally or from the peeps here like
what kind of music do you listen to you
got to [ __ ] I'm a hip-hop fan
neighbor Chen yeah we were just chatting
like for me my favorite artist right now
is Travis Scott like I feel like over
the last two years everything Travis
sauce has made has just been taps ball a
buyer like turned into gold so
definitely been it's definitely been a
huge Travis Scott fan being from Toronto
I love Drake and what about Kelly from
Toronto right I don't know Toronto has
so many has everyone Kelly well how do
you get job kil ly ly Rapids he's a
rapper
you're gonna love okay I'll take your
word for it he's huge to somebody like
Mike Boyd who lives in that world
exactly
he's this what so but by the way this is
what's so great about the game kilise
huge for people that look at the world
that way right this burger place is huge
for the wit like like it's just what
world are you in my weight that's why I
like this show even the way it's flowing
right now like this like I'm like in the
show but then my other part of my brains
like analyzing the show like this is
exactly right yeah these are people that
are in their world they know their
worlds their passion about their worlds
like you know you know five guys right
now who are gonna be the biggest
basketball players in the world in six
years that nobody else in this room
besides me has ever heard of right
because they're either a McDonald's
all-american or they're freshmen at
Oklahoma right now but they don't live
in that world but are you like what do
you mean you don't know yeah that's
yeah the crib I mean the craziness with
music for me is that like I guess I
don't really cert I don't search for
like the next like I don't go on like
YouTube in like yeah thank you and come
back I'm worried like you guys hear
about the weekend yeah yeah I'm very
similar to that when I'm not in Mike
Boyden mode at once every three or four
years I'll go into his world and I'll
get really in it which is what I'm in
right now and then other times I'm super
thrilled to just give me the seven songs
that are most opera and I need a little
Lionel Richie normally mixed in there as
well no ice machine is like a good like
if I always just like if I'm in my own
shoes just add on like popular mmm and
that's how I like find all my name is it
cuz I constantly am DJing yep and
sometimes i DJ an event where they're
like we'd actually like you to play
songs with no lyrics and I'm like okay
um and then other times it's like the
turn up so I should send you a bunch of
instrumentals yeah let me know are you
part of record pulls to like do they
feed you just like the new stuff being a
DJ or no you don't really know I mean
I've got a lot of friends who are
producers and they get like a bunch of
stuff from them um there's also this kid
have you heard of buddy yeah Santa fro
yeah yeah he's a buddy sex why do you
say he's a he actually performed at my
wedding
nice yeah it was the first time he ever
left the country as well he think it
from Compton when he got his passport
just for the wedding - yeah amazing it
was awesome buddy's a man yo you're
right though about like there's like
different worlds that are huge and if
you're not in them you don't know about
him well I mean it's you know honestly
that's in a weird way the purpose of
this format for me which is like
somebody who's consuming on the other
end is getting bounced around to four
different three different two different
kind of worlds and I think it's super
interesting and I think in a lot of ways
curation has always been unbelievably
important and gets compounded when
there's a lot of supply and so for me
the only reason I produce content is to
bring value to the audience period end
of story simple zero zero zero sum game
and so I'm always challenging myself to
be better and better and better I want
to be all-time I wanna be all [ __ ]
time and so like this format for me
isn't
rabble because that's what's being
provided right now right like if you're
on the other side of this you've like
literally just found three newb this one
knew that and obviously these shows are
taking very different forms every time
what do you wanna know Hannah um what do
I want to know I guess right now what
I'm really interested in is I'm kind of
in a space where I want to grow my brand
I don't want to necessarily have to
physically show up places to make money
yes which obviously kind of then you
know translates into product yes and
when I think about product obviously
marketing is a huge part of that and I
just wonder for me I really find that I
connect with products that have
integrity yes
and their marketing ends up being kind
of shitty yes as they've cared so much
about the integrity of the product
they're being too fancy and romantic
right corrine all the brands that are
doing really really well are like brands
that are actually like the product is
[ __ ] but the marketing is so on point
yes and I think the thing to think about
there that you may want to debate is
just the game of how long a game is
right so I think one thing that people
have to be thoughtful of is a shitty
product over the long term will lose you
know it would I think that as well you
know so one has to remember that you may
deem dub soap or coca-cola or cereal
Cinnamon Toast Crunch or Head &
Shoulders as shitty but you've got a
reverse engineer the context of the
market right so I think about music like
this all the time - since we're staying
on a theme or like sports like what I
love about sports is guess what the
shit's gonna play out on the court right
in front of your [ __ ] face like
there's gonna be no - but there's no you
can't talk trash it like like and then
like like Benny play and then it plays
out like you can be mad that a song is
number one on the charts and you're like
that's some [ __ ] [ __ ] guess what
the market [ __ ] spoke yeah and and so
that's how I think about products to us
a lot of people that have your profile
and taste and that's the truth are
getting into the product game of
speaking to a lot of them and they're
having this interesting point of view
this filter makes sense I think what's
interesting in this conversation is I've
blindly accepted the market and then try
to figure out what
I want to do within it so I'm kind of
doing that as well I think well so I'd
actually like if you I feel like you
kind of know my brand like what would
you say what would you think that the
product would be to make for you yeah
I've got a I've actually do have a
pretty good idea on this cuz obviously
we haven't had the chance to really chop
it up so it's like years in the pent up
making I think you have permission that
a lot of people don't to go completely
left [ __ ] field if you and I if let's
say this went and we got friendly and
you're like I really want to do a
business with you bless you Boyd and you
said I really want to do business with
you and be like okay only under one
circumstance we have to go to some weird
[ __ ] place bring in some product
nobody in America knows and it has to be
legit [ __ ] right like somebody figured
like pomegranates I was born in Russia
and Belarus specifically when I came to
America pomegranates were huge in the
Soviet Union when we came to America my
mom would go to like different stores to
seek him out and we would have
pomegranates in 1984 1987 1990 and my
American friends would come over in
those years and be like the [ __ ] is that
they'd never seen a pomegranate in their
life right right right and so like a lot
of people were listening who come from
cultural backgrounds like you know if
you go to a friend from Haiti they got
some [ __ ] food that's in a store it's
usually cultural so you're like what is
that what is that I think what's super
fascinating about your positioning in my
opinion from afar is you have permission
to like we should go to Peru and find
some random [ __ ] and like make like the
next like anti drink what else it
[ __ ] you have you can settle into the
easy part of like making another huh you
have upside to like be like you know
there's red bananas in the [ __ ]
Amazon jungle and they're making [ __ ]
like like lip cleaner like I'm you
should make some [ __ ] [ __ ] up that is
true though which is like the indigenous
people have been using this for 800
meters that is a permit that is a
remarkable opportunity for you that an
enormous amount of people who do not
have because there's not a credibility a
momentum and a star factor you need to
be really thoughtful because you have to
understand why if I'm right
and the products red and it hits the
economics are disproportionally crazy
because you have such a lead and an
ownership over a category not you're
just a good product within a category
right you're creating a [ __ ] category
mm-hmm interesting I agree with that
that was some sick little MBA down so
that's where I'm at with that cool I'm
glad I asked that who's your favorite
athlete growing up my favorite yes sir
LeBron James without a doubt really yeah
young [ __ ] are you 24
oh I was a huge a bran fan first time I
watched him play was in Toronto I was 11
years old he was kind of like just
starting out his career at that point
and like the first time he walked out of
the tunnel I cried I cried when I like
saw him in person and then by the time
my dad or mom or friend react to your
crying they I mean they just knew I was
obsessed with them so they just they're
like that's just Nick being Nick you
know I mean think of it but my obsession
got to the point where every year my
Christmas present was a trip to
Cleveland to watch the cats play so what
happened the first time of your team so
your rookie year my room tell me the
full story go your rookie year tell
everybody who you were drafted by I was
drawn to this don't think I was drafted
eighth overall by the Sacramento Kings
in 2014 and so I'm playing for the Kings
we're in Cleveland and like the whole
day like leading up to the game like my
stomach's just like in knots like like
my first year every game was exciting
because like every night I was going up
against someone that I had like looked
up to as a kid but LeBron was a
different story for me and so the game
starts and cry when you no I didn't cry
but like the game starts the game starts
and LeBron and I are like we play
different positions so we weren't like
guarding each other but then like maybe
a minute and a half two minutes into
like when I checked into the game I just
happened that like in transition like
there was a Miss shot we came down on
offense he like matched up with me and
he like called it out to he's like I got
Stauskas and I was like anyone else
my name and like for the whole
possession I didn't even touch the ball
I was just he was just like right next
to me and I was just like looking around
I was like everybody sees like LeBron is
guarding me right now did you have
something like that in the studio do you
have you always been always like look
what like I guess yeah something like
that because obviously he had other
players he appreciated that stories but
I mean like for real for real
first time I met Dre Dr Dre I mean Dre
was he's a guy yep
okay so 2013 I'm in LA and I'm at this
studio in LA and I got a call from my
guy who at the time just got hired to be
an A&R at aftermath and so I knew him
from like years ago when he was doing
some other stuff and so he's like you
lil what are you doing I'm like yo I'm
in LA I'm in a studio he's like yo I'm
out here I'm with Dre
where you at and I give him the address
of the studio and he's like yo me and
Dre are across the street at the bar so
I'm like like like dr. Dre yeah me and
Doc are over here he's like yo come
through say what come say what's up so I
leave the studio and I go into the bar
and like I see my man my man and Dre to
him and like I meet ray for the first
time I'm like super stoked he's like you
lil my I was so mad
yo my man ty he told me you got that
fire I'm all right and so we're like you
know having drinks he's like buy me a
shot he's like looking at me like yo yo
I can't wait to hit his joints I'm like
yeah you know okay then we'll get in and
he's like you got a studio now I'm like
yeah and so I'm like yeah come across
the street I'm actually in a session I
have the room so that we leave the bar
so it's me dr. Dre and my man team and
so we go into the studio and I'm 50%
super confident and stoked because I
love my [ __ ] yeah and like I can't wait
to show him that's awesome and then 50%
nervous as [ __ ] like oh my god I'm like
about to play my stuff for dr. Dre and
so he's sitting back there I'm like on
the ball
our speakers and then I plug my my
computer in and I start hitting play on
some beats like a minute per beat just
playing beats and I'm not looking back
cuz I'm super nervous I'm like in my
mind in my mind Dre is doing this like
he's walking out in the back and so I'm
like looking straight and I'm just
playing on my beats I'm like yeah I know
J [ __ ] with this I know he loves this I
know he loves this and then so a couple
beats in I to the back and dre is
looking down on his phone like we're
bored like not feeling anything and I
was like damn like my heart broke I was
like [ __ ] so anyway I stopped playing it
and then I had a convo with Dre he's
like you know he's like you should is
cool but like you know what he really
not not haven't heard before and then we
got into like a really deep conversation
he was like schooling me on stuff and
then that was that and then a year later
I come back to LA and then he's working
on natural project and we start working
together and he's shown me this was when
the NWA movie before it dropped he was
showing me like trailers of the movie
I'm like super stoked like dr. Dre is
showing me clips of the new NWA movie
that no one has seen yet so then we get
in studio again he's like yo am i
playing me some stuff and like he loved
everything and he was like yo and he
recorded some [ __ ] and then from there
we just started like a working
relationship so my first experience was
like terrible but then like because I
just kept going and kept at it I got it
now like every time I see Dre it's like
super amazing but I still get super
nervous around so it's always gonna be
Dre I had a moment this week this week
this week you had your core like again
remember these guys have met other
people but you're saying this is the one
to happen this week having this week
literally I had a shot of tequila with
Oprah oh wow
so your horn literally I mean that was
listen how much of tequila with Oprah
Winfrey are just not overtones open
sure in Harlem okay really got better
than that so they're ready mr. it was
not ready Marcus big shout out yeah guys
if you ever come to New York and you you
need to go to Red Rooster it's in Harlem
the flavors legit it's just a good
experience well go ahead
okay so the Studio Museum in Harlem is
like an iconic Museum here in New York
City my mom has done like tons of work
for them over the years I actually it
was a full circle situation so I'd been
going there so ever since I was in my
mom's snuggly pack and I got a call two
weeks ago asking it like a DJ the own
Network event at the studio Museum which
will be the last event and that will
ever take place in the studio Museum
because they are closing that building
tearing it down and building a new one
that is not true I'm gonna run there now
and put on an event cuz I want to be the
last of it I go and I'm like okay mom
you got to come to the event like this
is crazy I didn't even think Oprah was
gonna be there you know what I mean I
didn't I just thought I'm like DJing
like a corporate another corporate event
the other time it was gonna be uptown
full of black people so I was can be fun
right so I'm like I'm down so I go and
Oprah's there and next thing you know
I'm like on a second level so I'm like
oh I'm probably not gonna get to meet
her anything and next thing you know she
after she gives her speech she comes
upstairs introduce herself to me and
everyone in the whole place is gonna
take a shot of tequila and she hands me
her shot then gets another one cheers as
me says her whole thing we took a shot
together I mean granted oh it was also
with the other 100 people in the room
but he was all we were right next to
each other and she heard tequila like it
was a it was a major moment it was like
in it felt like and also it's like it's
Oprah like I aspire to have so many of
her qualities and make an impact on the
world like she has and it was just wow
I'll back Oprah [ __ ] awesome yeah
thanks
what is your first Instagram post I want
you to pull up your first point I do
what okay [ __ ] stream okay oh sorry
guys [ __ ] Instagram logo yeah let's
go Nick I want to I want to see it I'm
gonna I'm gonna experience it really
let's do they're just gonna keep
scrolling scroll to it it's me I
remember mine like it was yesterday
yeah alright pull it up pull it up wait
so I have to manually just click oh yeah
just function go into him if you're
listening you know chuan is Instagram if
you're listening right now we'd like you
to like add a button that allows you go
directly to your first time do that like
yeah it takes a while and you know how
it like does the lighting so yeah take
you forever I know we're gonna keep
doing scribe it no no I wanna I wanna
really remember well this is a very fun
thing this is a new game this is just
created on the spot what is your first
Instagram photo ever
I see sick Tyler Smith is doing it also
anaconda legend is here but he's not
doing it he's too [ __ ] fresh to do it
I want to see what everybody's first
Instagram photo is and as a matter of
fact for everybody listening I'm gonna
do a contest I'm gonna send somebody
five sign books five this is where you
can sell them for twenty bucks on eBay
make some cash to one person randomly go
to your phone go to your profile go to
your first Instagram photo ever
screenshot your phone tweet it at me and
put hashtag GV first yeah GV first
they'll be fine I'll find it and I'm
gonna pick one of yours IG okay fine
thanks HP GV first IG because we're
collaborating here and I will pick one
of you
you found a Nick found it Nick what is
it keep going out much Hannah I'm going
like not my wife Ines [ __ ] bad-ass
don't try to diss on the Wi-Fi keep I'm
oncology I'm not even Nick's first photo
ever is with LeBron James Wow
2012 that was worth creating an account
yeah I created the account for that
picture I think that's insane that's
unbelievable how did you get what
happened you were a good player in the
gutter why do you have this photo that
was my first year at the University of
Michigan and one of my teammates who now
play one of my teammates at Michigan
Timmy here he played with me and his
father worked for the heat at that time
right and so the Heat were playing the
Pistons in Detroit don't give up your
big fan of her work can you please
scroll her Instagram I was keeping
scroll Hannah's Instagram she just
reached 20 I'm on 2014 right now I I
mean how many posts have you NIC how
many posts have you post on your
Instagram um says it's one of those 623
623 okay I wanted you 3500 yeah okay I'm
good yeah I'm still going while you guys
are doing this
I want everybody also to go and look at
Oprah's first-ever Instagram photo how
are you supposed to do both at the same
time well you're not supposed to do that
but we'll have somebody do that well why
don't you do that Seth we're gonna pull
up Oprah since we just talked about her
her first Instagram photo as well I love
Oprah you love her so much right I
really did should be pretty iconic for
her she's powerful yeah honestly like
she commands attention she like speaks
with such authority and like
vulnerability
it's like she's doing an old Nick
no-look scroll yes i Dre has that same
like you know when certain people say
anything I love that song by the way
neon guts yeah yeah I love that smell
guts is my [ __ ] I always like I have a
running list in my notes of good like
rap lyrics that would make a good
Instagram caption and that's one of them
like neon guts and
man hey man how's your scrolling coming
along I mean it's going that's going I'm
at 28 we've got Oprah's first photo
let's see what it is this is fine
actually what what what is it are you
for real
I what date is that this is really
upsetting this is April 25th 2012 and
Oprah's first photo is of Gary B no
dad's just trying to live life out here
that's crazy that was fun [ __ ] a little
fun for me actually so far Nix was with
LeBron
Oprah's first photo was with me my first
photo it's gonna be ridiculous like
actually on the Mike's a year it was
actually New Year's Eve when I posted my
first and I think it was New Year's of
2012
well Nick I did as a kid while these
guys are going through that we're gonna
go through a favorite toy singular
favorite toy as a child oh you know what
it was called yes I just love your face
how you actually figured it out there's
a beatbox you know it's like like twist
it pull it dear ex having a great day
yeah I mean you just came in here nice
and slow you know yeah we know I'm glad
you're here how you know what about some
of these pecs
these are good goodness you got some
good stuff see ya got some recall it's
not every day you go through your entire
feed yes hi what's cool about Instagram
to like and especially successful people
like you get to see like where that
cutoff point was of like oh they got
money now
like wearing like like no no I mean like
garbage cans I what about your favorite
toy of all no yeah of all time [ __ ] it
must have been a Star Wars thing like a
Star Wars toy house or I'm 35 got it yes
so some tarnished Jedi Star Wars was
before my time see I know was returned I
you Jam like were you there for that no
you were you born
I don't even you do not know your birth
year bro you're 82 forget about me and
Oprah like that was never seen before
I've never seen somebody struggle so
hard at least that wasn't in their 90's
of where they were born under your first
photo I'm so close what is what is your
favorite all-time toy as a kid um I
don't know like I don't think I played
with toys I really I did I mean I like I
love I played a lot of video games when
I was a kid like two loved um like that
I can't even lead I was saying this but
I love that terrible Sega game Ecco the
Dolphin oh no I'm gonna change my answer
it was video of mine [ __ ] was videogames
is no life
I was I was a dancer my favorite like my
dancing gym I love basketball shoes you
know I never owned a pair of shoes in my
entire life because I hate him with all
my [ __ ] heart why cuz I'm a Knicks
fan in any real [ __ ] Knicks fan
here's Michael [ __ ] Jordan but like
you respect the greatness though of
course of course more weight you don't
ask me who my favorite sports person why
I don't know if that was just like a
gender you ask Nick who is favorite we
get contractual to his world basketball
plane was Patrick Ewing cuz I'm a Knicks
fan I love you wait was he was my
favorite all-time player he's the best I
saw ma matumbo once in a club and I
could I take a vote of them and he the
finger he did the finger no next flex
moment well [ __ ] this I'm doing it go
Anthony Mason so I was in I was in 83
see in Atlanta and I shared an elevator
with Anthony Mason Mason senior senior
okay and and he said that his son is a
fan of my listen to my elevator wait
Mason right now me I've also another
little sports situation my uncle Lou
started the Gauchos oh I used to play
against Gauchos oh yeah yeah yeah and I
all right August 31st 2011 11 it's a
picture of where's my uh what is it on
[ __ ] quiz his name Tyler wait a
minute I don't give a [ __ ] if it's
[ __ ] midnight I asked you to get to
the first photo you gave up in like two
seconds I oh my god
okay so happy everybody has theirs but
mine so Mary Tyler whose -
in situations like this literally just
disregarded my request nicely that you
have a Harry Potter wand it's Harry
Potter I chose a nerd five likes to
comments what did I say what were the
comments the comments were you [ __ ]
nerd guys first coming to I'm a half
Filipino kid from Bloomfield who manages
got some hay yeah that's wrong bump okay
swag yeah I told you me and this is 27
likes one comment january 5th 2012 its
fireworks it was from New Year's Eve
comment my first and only wife looks
something like you cuz then I wouldn't
have problems doing anything it takes to
keep her happy that's three hundred and
eighteen weeks ago just like yesterday's
I should have started with this was the
second post me in the studio was the
hashtag GB it's the GV first insta no GD
no GV first IG g v first IG okay thank
you guys back it like the early stays
like the early days of your Instagram
you realize was I even I'm up to we're
not up to the things you're up to now
except fast what's up still killing the
nail-art game though let's get real yeah
you that's really been on it early
you're up on that yeah okay since the
90s you know yeah guys I really
appreciate having you on last parting
words for the audience what he got to
say Hannah um last parting words you the
audience anything you want Russians
statements inspirations D motivations
whatever is whatever you pull with I
don't know do like do what makes you
feel good yeah good I like that Nick be
great perfect your craft I think like
for me that's what motivates me like I
I just look at guys that are like the
best in their sport or like their
professional I look at guys like Tom
Brady like in the Super Bowl like dude
you just we don't talk I'm literally
looking at you with a huge Jets logo
over your head like no no above its you
right this is my anger oh yeah you
noticed you know how I talked about the
Jordan thing earlier Brady's on some
more current feeling [ __ ] even someone
like like Floyd Mayweather no no just
all about practice yes every day whether
it's 3:00 in the morning 4:00 in the
morning like he just goes to Jimmy's
like yeah I want to be the best ever and
he's 50 and oh because of it yep so hey
great don't you do a mime I would say
man just try a bunch of [ __ ] until you
find something you're obsessed with
doing
yeah just like to do it every day yes
guys I really appreciate you have a
great weekend
appreciate you having me so you got it
wait that was actually unbelievable
timing Tyler you actually did this
perfectly because if you had it earlier
we would have had this incredible moment
on pod sessions number four I can't wait
to see what it is don't say anything let
me see it is it ridiculous oh my god
it's a picture of my daughter I'm such a
better human than you guys see ya Harry
Potter wand
204 comments 512 likes eat [ __ ] guys